[Music]
and I think before you tweet news
submitted by spilled the milk Tia oh
that's an Asian drama aging and gaming
company dropped a female streamer for
calling men trash well is it because of
other reasons because that sounds
ridiculous you can guess what color her
hair color is it sure is
Oh what is it maurizio cyan it is like a
reddish color Oh true well that's not as
bad as that time wait I saw a different
picture her though isn't that natural
yeah right you sent me the article I did
my homework this is the photo that was
used in the article okay let me go
debunk you oh really because this is the
other photo that was in the article okay
true true I'm sweating gamers say a lot
of crazy [ __ ] why does she get fired for
calling guys trash on guys trash in the
first place
yet it's not trash you know I begun
trash you're not trash thank you think
Bart's trash yeah I do have your back
feet I'm saying he's not trash
that's right stick up for your man yeah
I never do that so relish in that okay I
am I'm Fang he might not all right so
really here's the photo that I showed
that who Daniella she does not have blue
hair yes
Gabriela she tweeted a photo of herself
in a mechanical bull which that's when a
guy waited back saying uh you can ride
me if you want by the way
Oh God funny and Portuguese cuz she's
from Brazil so these are just the
translated versions of what was
happening and so she responded to that
quote there's always going to be [ __ ]
in the head macho man to talk [ __ ] and
sexualized women until the woman starts
making jokes right and this is why men
are trash then she followed up by saying
not all men are trash is just that that
wasn't good enough for her sponsor the
gaming company which is razor
and it still dropped it is razor a
Brazilian company I don't know it sucks
when you can't just say something
anymore you have to like make sure to
clarify hey I'm not talking about
literally everybody because I back her
up actually there is dirt there is a
[ __ ] group of guys out there that are
kind of trash
especially Brazilian dudes yeah that are
super sexual yes of n right there in the
posting a statement saying we would like
to make it clear that Gabby is not a
spokesperson for razor and has never
been a brand ambassador she was part of
a team of influencers who were called
upon to use and publicize the brand's
product as gamers we face every type of
preconception and stereotype from the
outset and we will continue fighting so
that this type of situation doesn't
repeat itself
hahaha gamers yeah razor feels like
they're fighting for like gender rights
or equality or quality I guess it's like
what the [ __ ] you heard the [ __ ] that
people say in games in like to each
other and I feel like that is like the
last remaining safe space that we got
where we can talk a lot of [ __ ] and be
as racist and crazy name we need to be
yeah her comments as extremism tactics
where the [ __ ] is his world coming to
what does she play like [ __ ]
bejeweled like what right yeah made
farmville she [ __ ] I know like what I
don't picture her like blink call it do
it here's some hardcore ass game that's
your sexism your Nate sexism yeah
biggest can't play call of duty [ __ ]
could play call dude mutts can play
called my point the point is I can't
imagine her being in that world and
playing those hardcore games and not
talking like that like a twelve-year-old
playing call of duty says the craziest
[ __ ] is my favorite do you play games
I'm occasionally if I like Mortal Kombat
and just like Fighter games pretty good
way with the stick to stick in your lap
thing but this day I okay no no I know
some real freaks freaks who they buy
those arcade joystick set up
unscrew the little thing and they put
one it has extra grip on top I keep
feeling like you're about to say like
they're gonna splay their dick in there
sometimes I thought that's what the [ __ ]
so horny yeah thank you just me yeah
clarify that who's the little [ __ ] that
got their feelings hurt because whenever
I hear like razors the one that got the
feelings are razor Brazil is the one so
then a new spokesperson wouldn't give a
comment to the reporter that was
reporting this article but they did
other people are responding to this
whole thing saying like there's one
tweet said I was going to buy a razer
Mouse but I just found out it is a trash
company who fires the oppressed and
protect the offer I love Gabi it was
good who fires the oppressed
that's [ __ ] jokes man two people that
are offended there's a huge contingent
of people out there who feel like they
as white people are discriminated
against because of their whiteness and
it's that group here I think really yeah
I would say like half of them are
serious
and half of them are just kids trolling
and I think that's the majority of
outrage [ __ ] is people just egging it on
and [ __ ] around yeah
and also people that are really serious
about it I think that they take a little
tiny thing like this like a girl's chick
saying guys are trash to a guy right and
then they go they try to act offended to
try to get sympathy towards them and
their community culture yes but did that
happen like did the company's theater
immediately or with people like at
raiser like if you're gonna let your a
person talk to us like this like what
good question I wouldn't be surprised if
people use that as a way to take her
down because you also have to think like
gamer girls have it hard because you do
have cooks that want to [ __ ] them and
they they're sexually frustrated and
they attack them that way and some some
of them don't aren't seen as legitimate
gamers because they're girls and they're
cute and they're like oh you're using
that as there's just two kinds of
caution
the term for it yeah there's so much
controversy behind just being a female
and gaming that people are just waiting
to just take them down and talk some
[ __ ]
I always think chicks can't play games
as well if they're hot but what don't
you always lose to Nikki always no I
know I'm just talking about innately
because when I was a kid like when you
think of like Pamela Anderson holding
like a gamecube controller which I think
I saw in an ad one time how's the life
side down I was like a producer just
handed that said she's like whatever
that they take the picture like I don't
think of it like oh she was definitely
playing games because I never saw that
growing up in movies TV shows everything
hot chicks like games like every time so
that's why I lately think that but do
you think when you see a really hot
professional gamer chick to that like
changer yeah I think she's a fraud oh
you can't hear a disbelief because
they're so good but you're like someone
else's [ __ ] controlling that [ __ ]
there's literally a gameboy add of all
like a thirteen-year-old boy and he's
laying in bed and Lauren Holly in her
prime 1993 or some [ __ ] she's in a
bikini holding a gameboy and like nachos
or some [ __ ] or pizza and the kid like
is looking at the Gameboy no I'm like
that's why I am so seeing all this [ __ ]
I'm like hot chicks and gains and the
kid picks the games and I got chicks
don't even think the games is cool yeah
I mean it was like we had our own
programming yes kind of like how girls
grew up with the Barbie dolls right so
then yeah guys kind of grew up thinking
that pretty girls don't like games yes
cuz it's lame that's like 20 years ago
like that yeah I mean we think that all
men ladies say about how they're forced
to feel like like they have to look a
certain way right so I think it's the
same kind of kid programming that that
kids grow up and go oh only nerds like
games trying to say that I got oppressed
I don't feel like I'm being heard here
did this other photo car on the back no
I don't have that photo but they do
mention in case you guys are curious how
many followers she has so she has 68,000
on Facebook which is where she usually
streams and another 89 thousand
followers on Twitter I like the fact
that guys are outraged about
Kull trash with their they get their
feelings hurt and they want to be
respected as a man it's like you gotta
be above that like what the [ __ ] will do
we did an article this morning where a
bunch of guys are yelling at a girl
because she said she would do porn and
then she trolled them by putting silly
things on pornhub and they're like we
should make her do porn force if I do
porn
guys aren't trash yeah cuz it's so I can
make her do porn devicive now there's
like girls that are thinking mall guys
are trash and there's guys that are
thinking all women are certain way yes
and that's like the lowest level of
thinking it's super low IQ well cuz that
doesn't happen in real life so do you
think that because there's this
anonymity on the internet that people
are now really speaking their minds or
is it just this blown-up thing that I
think people with low IQs online or not
online that's how they think like when
people are like oh all guys are sexual
harasser or molesters are all trash I
never go I can't be they're gonna talk
to talk about me that way yes
cuz I know there's just millions of
different types of dudes and I
immediately exclude myself from that
list I'm like I can empathize with what
she's saying because I know those dudes
do exist but I know she's not talking
about me yeah it's lazy thinking yes
well then what about in the position
though and vice versa
of razor where they felt like it's such
an important topic that they have to
make this stance so that it doesn't show
that they're supporting no thank you
company looks like your boy right no
you're right they see that the majority
of the world are kind of tribal and they
are kind of stupid
this is a business move we don't want to
be tied to this kind of thinking or this
kind of bad publicity so let's just let
go of that it might not be funny
from from the way I viewed this entire
story it seems as though I could be
wrong cuz I'm not Brazilian but it seems
as though this whole thing didn't blow
up until they responded to it so like
before it wasn't even a big thing but
then because they dropped her
no it is a big thing because everyone's
like why did you drop her yeah
ninety percent of their client base is
probably men yeah so this is like a win
for them either way it's not
and lose support because girls are
outside that's true I mean they would
have got my respect if they were like
dopes she stood up for herself and men
talk trash don't work oh yeah would you
buy a gaming keyboard after that gl [ __ ]
no they don't give a [ __ ] but then but
then would you buy the keyboard
wouldn't you be like oh [ __ ] that's
tight like they're empowering chicks or
you'd be like I don't give a [ __ ] what
just happened that doesn't affect me
nice I want to see if it's cheap and
there's a lot of functions
it's a deal right that's what I buy yeah
that's why I was asking like like the
this razor company they made it such a
big they made this seem like it's a
bigger problem than what it really is
here's the thing I'll answer your
question yeah please that if the
keyboard has the clicky keys that I can
piss my wife off with then yeah - right
Gabi ended up posting a statement on
Twitter saying that this whole situation
started a witch hunt and that she never
intended to be a Miss Andrus and that
she doesn't usually respond to
harassment but such that's uh and she
said quote I was an [ __ ]
I apologize was he an [ __ ] - yes but
I reacted ten times worse no you didn't
even do it there I said that she's
taking a break for social media due to
death threats against Harlan oh god yeah
this is stupid yeah it's hard to take
death threats online seriously though
yeah what I think it's overdone everyone
does it
yeah like everyone gets it and everyone
does it who hasn't gotten death threats
online every crazy those aren't those
the people that like a lot to your house
oh yeah your address leaked inside of
your house
[Music]